hello everyone and welcome to another
hard fought game uh from defeated grand
prix 2022 it's round five and it's
servings and camera versus levon arun uh
let's dive straight into it as uh there
is quite a lot to cover uh so kymer with
the white pieces opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 c4 e6 knight to f3 and d5
so the queen's gambit declined this on
the board
knight to c3 and the bishop to b4 we
have daragoza in defense queen to a for
check this i believe the most popular
continuation now uh knights the c6
blocking check and defending defending
your bishop here and just e3 preparing
to develop the light square bishop we
have castles by levon and now queen back
to c2 uh
there are a couple of other moves you
could play for example bishop d2 is the
most popular one queen to c to the
second most popular and now black
usually goes something like rook to e8
or is going to play b6 preparing bishop
to b7 bishop to a6 or even d captures on
c4 but here we have the very early queen
to e7 by the one and it is now already
as of move seven that we have a
completely new game
uh and okay now the the rooks are very
easily connected you can develop the
bishop the queen is uh
keeping an eye on that bishop there and
already you might have some ideas of
even striking in the center as the white
king is in the center of the board so
here
we have bishop to d2 and now d captures
on c4 bishop captures on c4 and that's
exactly what leveling does he plays e5
he strikes in the center
so d5 we are not interested in opening
up the center our king is still on e1
and now not moving the knight but rather
queen to c5 the bishop on c4 is
undefended so vincent goes knight to e4
now the queen defends the bishop and um
knight on c6 is still hanging so first
knight captures an e4 queen captures an
e4 and not knight back to e7 and here we
have knight captures on e5 so another
game uh where uh young vincent grabs a
pawn uh and well
will he
be able to
uh
to survive as his kings is still in the
center of the board it's it's a it's a
very dangerous move uh but if it works
he's gonna be up a pawn so here bishop
to f5 attacking the queen queen to f4
and now bishop captures on d2 so already
we can feel that black has compensation
even though he's down upon he already uh
prevented the white from castling and
now okay white will be able to bring the
rooks into the game but the king isn't
um
on a very safe square so queen b for
check and now king to c1 now
unfortunately you have to disconnect
your rooks if you play something like
king to d1 then queen captures on b2 and
this is not very ugly the bishop can
come to c2 queen can come to c2
the rook is hanging on a1 so and not a
lot of fun so king c1 we have to defend
our b2 pawn and now queen back to c5 now
we are again on the same file as the
king b5 is the threat and we want to win
this bishop on c4
vincent doesn't allow it he strikes with
g4 he says i'm the one who's attacking
here and indeed if levon goes b5 we
would see g captures b captures and now
something like knight d7 attacking the
rook and the queen and the white would
just be much better here
so instead after g4 uh we have g5 by
levon and this was not an easy move to
find but
it's uh
it really does wonders the the idea is
uh that now if queen captures on g5 you
can simply play bishop to g6 and the
knight can't really move uh since it has
to keep an eye on the bishop and b5 is
still coming so we really don't have all
that much to do here it's uh it's a very
ugly position for for white so instead
after this g5 move vincent finds another
brilliancy and that is pawn to b4 that
always a very nice idea and now not only
is the white queen hanging but also the
black queen is hanging and the idea is
that if well you still shouldn't capture
it's pretty much the same idea so you
have to
uh you have to try something uh so queen
captures uh
uh on b4 is played uh if you trade
queens uh g captures on f4 then b
captures on c5 and now it's it's
actually white who's better so instead
we have queen captures on b4 and now we
have queen to d4 again capturing here is
never a good idea you just have to keep
an eye on this bishop here so queen to
d4 now you don't have to worry about b5
the black queen is not on c5 and now
knight to g6 uh offering a trade here uh
and then now comes uh well uh bishop
back to b3 if you go g captures on f5
which obviously is a move uh knight
captures an e5 and again if queen
captures queen captures and c4 with
check the
position of white's king simply makes
the position much better for black so
instead after knight g6 with bishop back
to b3 by vincent even though there was a
very very tricky line here instead of
all of this you could play knight
captures on f7 and it's funny but look
at the bishop here that bishop might be
a very important piece if if played
properly but the thing is let's say
queen a3 check king to d2 now we play
rook captures on f7 g captures on f5
first attacking the knight and now after
real captures now we played d6 check for
example king f8 and now we capture here
and it's a complete mess of a position
uh the engine says it's uh
it's actually an equal position but who
would consider himself equal here
especially with little time on the clock
especially vincent he was already very
much down on the clock but uh
it was the best thing to do maybe
so instead like i said after knight g6
bishop back to b3 and now queen to a3
check uh where if you block with the
queen we can trade sure but after
captures captures you pick up the knight
on e5 now g captures on f5 and this is
just uh better for black now there's not
much for for white uh to hope for here
the df pawns are doubled and there
doesn't seem to be much for for black to
play for so after queen to a3 check king
to d2 uh vincent for the moment still
keeps the king in the center and now c5
uh challenging the queen trying to open
up some lines so hoping for d captures
on c6 so we can play knight captures on
e5 and so on open up the lines um
towards the white king so here queen
back to c3 and now knight captures an e5
but now g captures on f5 you could
capture the knight first but this is a
little bit better as we are hoping to
get a rook on the g file so rook f38
defending this knight rook h to g1 and
now b5 now levont is starting the attack
on the queen side for real uh and you
have to be very very careful but vincent
goes for it rook captures on g5 came to
h8 and now
uh the position is very delicate but
vincent is already down to i don't know
maybe five minutes on the clock uh you
have to play rook eight to g1 and now
with all this pressure uh the position
is very good for you black will of
course play f6 defend the knight attack
the rook here and once the rook moves uh
you have to
face the attack on the queen side for
example c4 we're gonna move the bishop
and now white is okay if black trades it
it's really not all that impressive and
the pawn on a2 cannot be captured
because of rook to a1 traps the queen so
uh rook 8 to g1 is the way to go here
but vincent plays bishop to d1 he wants
to put the bishop on e2 and then play
rook 8 to g1 but this is much much
slower and doesn't give vincent uh as
much uh play as the immediate rook eight
to g1 would have so queen to a6 but now
bishop p2 okay you have some pressure
here but now rook 8 d8 putting pressure
on the d5 pawn so e4 vincent defends it
and now queen to a4 uh here probably
vincent uh maybe thought as he was
already a minute on the clock that levon
just unpinned and he quickly played rook
to h5 and rook to h5 is a is a very
dangerous plan
but you have to play f3 the e4 pawn has
to be protected and now if b for queen
b3 we continue the game we always offer
a queen trade while uh having the the
strong center here
but here after rook to h5 um everything
just completely collapses this is what
vincent missed levon played rook queen
captures on e4 and now rook the g1 maybe
he didn't miss it maybe he gave it
willingly because white is threatening a
checkmate here but only only if black
allows him if black makes one slow move
for example rook captures on d5 check
was played king to c1 and now let's say
black makes a move a6 and gives y to
move then we have rook captures on h7
and black is getting checkmated queen to
h3 check uh there's nowhere for the king
to hide you have to give up the queen
and it's checkmate so instead after king
to c1 olive one of course knows that he
has to continue checking uh queen to f4
check king to b1 and now a nice safety
move rook to d4 and now the same idea no
longer works because not only does the
queen have access to the h6 square but
also the rook will be guarding the queen
just to show you very quickly queen h3
check now we can block with queen to h4
or queen to h6 so here uh bishop
captures and b5 but by vincent but now
absolutely everything is winning for
levon and he has more than 10 minutes on
the clock so here rook to b4 with check
we have king to a1 now comes rook
captures on b5
and here rook to e1 again uh it doesn't
matter that the rook left the defense of
the h4 square if vincent goes for for
the kill a queen h3 we can always block
with queen to h6 so that's the problem
so here rook the e1 was played and now
levon just played f6 he uh consolidated
his knight on e5 and he was in this
position on move 35 that vincent kymer
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here and this is uh uh
not often that you will see such
placement of the rooks okay this rook
would be a little bit better if it was
an a5 but it would be hanging on a5 so
okay we can
say it's okay mb5 but a fine position to
attain the game with
uh and you resign you're down a full
piece and there's really no compensation
there's no plan here white will just
collapse in the next few moves
uh so uh that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it not really uh a pause the
video moment because that uh one moment
where
uh things really have gone wrong for
vincent uh was uh well uh
leaving the e4 pawn hanging that's just
a terrible blunder but if you're down to
a minute on the clock and uh well uh but
still f3 you just play f3 and then okay
the same thing can still be played if
levon doesn't trade queens but for some
reason uh vincent missed this and well
that uh the rest is history and after
the game uh during an interview lavon
said i think vincent was having a lot of
fun as well his play was very daring and
full of desire to win the game otherwise
i wouldn't get the chance to win against
such a strong opponent so levon praised
him for playing such a fine attacking
game
but
well you also have to be mindful of the
clock so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed that i would like to thank the
hoodie knight god for making me an
atheist john anderson sorry about that
in this position feel free to pause the
video and the jonathan kemp for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
grand prix until it ends so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day